en france nous sommes au stade 2 avec un
objectif très clair qui est celui de
freiner la propagation du virus sur le
territoire national en terme de bilan ce
jour à 16 heures nous avons selon santé
publique france 191 cas confirmés soit
61 cas de plus
[Musique]
il n'y a toujours pas d'épidémie en
france on a devant nous c'est une
épidémie qui a rayé ce soit il ya là des
vidéos ans nous avons identifié un
regroupement de douze cas qui semblent
liés entre eux par une chaîne de
contamination
[Musique]
voulons répondre à cette inquiétude en
utilisant la seule méthode qui vaille
face aux risques la mobilisation le
calme et la raison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le dira jamais assez lavez vous les
mains lavez vous les mains souvent
toutes les heures
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]